you know what blows my mind what the
fact that we all have access and we do
to the exact same information and some
will take action when they receive new
information and actually become
successful others will receive new
information and then just go play video
games that's the difference between
being successful and not being
successful there's nothing else it's
just action wait wait but GTA 6 is
coming out what's that it's a video game
GTA that's why you're still poor because
you're busy watching the news playing
video games when you're given new
information you have to take action and
that's what I talk about in my private
telegram group every day I'm in there
broadcasting different ways that my team
and I make money online how we're making
money from anywhere in the world so if
you are lazy and you know you are
playing GTA then you're going to get a
notification from Leia telling you the
best ways to make money in 2023 and 2024
get in there I'm going to leave my
telegram link for you in description